o
hola muchísimas gracias
en realidad vengo a compartirla es una
historia que uno no le elige pero la
vida te embarca en eso y este viaje
arranco acá cuando tenía 8 años y vi un
grafiti en el barrio en mi barrio allí
en guayaquil y la llave y decía si el
reto no te hace temblar las piernas
quizás no es lo suficientemente grande
para ti yo en ese momento y lo entendí
ocho años nueve años pero el punto era y
me quedé pensando si una cosa es reto
otra cosa de actividad reto tiene que
hacerte temblar las piernas tiene que
sonar absurdo tiene que ser una idiotez
hacerlo debes ir a comentarle a tu
familia tu novia quien sea y te dicen
eso es imposible no se puede hacer esa
es la principal diferencia entre reto y
actividad y a mí me ocurrió eso y yo que
estaba en guayaquil había regresado de
estudiar y me cambia quito por un tema
de trabajo habrán sido hace unos cuatro
años me cambia quito y yo que no sentí
te lo que creo que es en donde se basa
la belleza del ecuador montañas nevados
páramos lagos lagunas una maravilla
entera y yo que venía corriendo un
kilómetro un kilómetro y medio en
guayaquil ruta llegó a quito y me
embarqué y me doy cuenta que puedo
correr más tiempo y más distancia
básicamente porque estaba entretenido y
pues a pues con la boca abierta bien de
corriente y dice qué cosa y resuelve
embarcando en una carrera que había cada
una en uganda acá en imbabura que que
tenía categorías 10 20 50 y 80
kilómetros entonces dije bueno sí ya
estoy corriendo 5 kilómetros 10 puede
ser un reto interesante
voy a inscribirme y el man me dice mira
10 y 20 están llenos 50 y 80 si quieres
y le dio dame 50 pues entonces entonces
y me da 50 porque según yo 50 menos que
80 pero también es diez veces más lo que
venía corriendo y me embarco en este
relajo 15 horas corriendo sufriendo la
sufrí infernalmente la acabo y me quedo
con una duda si mi duda era si las
personas realmente evolucionamos cuando
enfrentamos a nuestros miedos y esa duda
me estuvo martillando y martillando y
martillando seis meses después estaba
embarcada en la patagonia argentina
una carrera de 160 km mi cálculo fue
bastante alegre bueno si ya corre hasta
50 esto es cómo hacer unas tres vueltas
y una yapa de días nomás ese fue mi
cálculo me escribí compra el pasaje y me
embarqué en la patagonia 58 horas me
demoré la puede acabar pero mi duda
quedó resuelta las personas si
evolucionamos cuando enfrentamos a
nuestros miedos y ya cuando agarras
confianza en este tipo de cosas
una tarde buscando cosas importantes
como si habrá bajado el precio del
concierto pero no más sobre vestido de
la kardashian o lo que sea yo puse la
carrera más difícil en el mundo no para
hacerla solamente por sapo y para ver
qué pasaba y esto me embarga al desierto
del sahara a pretende correr 240
kilómetros en el lugar más caliente del
planeta es la carrera considerada la más
difícil en el mundo por nadie yo te dije
mira yo no yo no soy un correo era
tiempo completo ya intento compartir
esto con mi trabajo con mi familia y
demás y digo
pero si en 29 años ningún ecuatoriano le
había acabado a mí me gustaría ser el
primero y me embarcó en esta aventura
intentar correr en estos nueve meses de
entrenamientos cinco pares de zapatos
gastados acaba tiempo debajo de la
piedra y me iba a guayaquil a correr al
mediodía a mí no me gusta el vallenato y
me ponía el vallenato ahí a correr a el
mediodía calentaba agua me la llevaba
porque tenía el desierto no escrito más
agua para refrescarte puesto más agua
para hidratar con otra cosa entonces no
tomaba agua efe agua él ha tomado agua
caliente y bueno al final del día quiero
compartirles la primera el primer
resumen mío es que básicamente nosotros
tenemos que enfocarnos en metas si hoy
no se levantaron ustedes con algo en la
cabeza que está muy claramente
identificado están teniendo el tiempo y
eso les pudo haber pasado la semana
pasada y el mes pasado si no tienen algo
en la cabeza están perdiendo el tiempo
si la respuesta es hoy llegué al trabajo
porque estoy esperando que me paguen fin
de mes para pagar deudas están perdiendo
el tiempo
plantense en algo que tengan en la
cabeza que sí lo tienen intenten agarrar
algo no les garantizo que lo van a
cumplir pero sí les garantizo que al
menos le van a dar sentido a su vida y
eso pasó conmigo y yo estuve siete meses
intentando internados para esto porque
me estaba metiendo al sahara 1.200
corredores 48 países y había un
ecuatoriano ahí que no tenía idea en
dónde estaba metido pero según yo iba a
acabar la carrera más difícil en el
mundo y bueno y me embarco fíjense en lo
que pasó
es un día
por qué
la puedes repetir para cancelar más
rápido y muerte
igual que estamos en confianza
bueno vas y te motiva solito no
una hora después
los he vuelto a apoyarme
en los metatarsos sobre las ampollas
para dejarlos descansar a los talones
y así
así pasaré creo que el resto del día y
así pase el resto del día por más que
uno se plantee que esto empieza que todo
lo que tú quieras que vamos a ecuador
que el mundo perfecto que ya lo dice en
excel y lo es en power point la vida
real de esa otra cosa y en una hora me
dio un par de cachetadas y me dijeron un
nuevo ministro tú estás en el sahara
está en calor estás a 48 grados a 50
grados ya sufren se ha dicho porque son
seis días y debes correr 240 kilómetros
esos eran los primeros 40 kilómetros
míos y yo esa noche veo por primera vez
una persona que casi muere al frente mío
él es pablo compañera de tuvieron que
colocar de 5 sueros para mantenerlo vivo
se había deshidratado tanto que ya no
había vuelta atrás cinco suelos
imagínense para tenerlo vivo que pasó
con pablo y qué reflexión quiero
compartirles pablo está en el mismo
lugar que yo aguantando el mismo calor
que yo sufriendo con la arena como yo y
tenía la misma botella de agua que yo le
habían dado lo mismo sin embargo pablo
fue más conservador y dijo voy a
utilizar
no la cantidad de mis recursos para
seguir en carrera que ocurrió al final
pablo se quedó con la botella llena y al
borde de la muerte y eso es exactamente
lo que nos puede pasar a nosotros
nosotros tenemos una botella de sueños
de recursos de capacidades de
inteligencia de motivación de apoyo y
cada uno tiene su propia botella cuidado
cuidado puede pasarnos un modelo de
pretextos pasamos inventándonos
cualquier cosa con tal de no habría esa
botella cuidado nos agarra la muerte
porque no sé si se han dado cuenta pero
aquí nadie sabe cuándo se va a morir
cuidado nos agarran la muerte con la
botella de nuestros recursos
completamente llena o usa muy poquito y
eso le pasó a pablo ustedes tienen que
tomar retos no actividades retos
enfocarse en un proyecto y trabajarlo
como ustedes solamente lo pueden hacer
eso es retos no estamos hablando de
actividades y bueno al siguiente día y
bueno sigue es una tormenta de arena no
ustedes puede venció ni aún vencido
continuemos en esta aventura y vamos
paso a paso
siguiendo estas corriendo pero no padres
no padres como la vida no pares sigue y
ahí vamos y que hay arena los padres y
que hay mucho sol no pares y sigamos
caminando ampollas sigamos y se
complicaron yo pensé que iban a salir en
el día 3 me salieron en el día 1 pero
sigamos vamos día 2 avanzando estos son
mis pies ya me los habían curado
tuvieron que cortarme la piel en los dos
pies con un bisturí para sacar sangre ya
y yo esa noche no podía caminar y ahí
llevaba 80 kilómetros recorridos
faltaban 160 kilómetros recibió a 80 y
el problema es que no podía caminar y
estaba muerto de miedo como la vida si
la tenía la meta clara pero ya me había
cambiado el plan y no importa cuántas
veces cambiemos el plan siempre y cuando
la meta esté muy clara y sigamos
avanzando y bueno al siguiente día me lo
encuentro a luis y luís me enseña una
lección de vida que fue esta yo
quejándome por las ampollas que en algún
momento se me iban a cuidar pero a luís
no le iban a salir dos brazos nuevos
y allí es cuando ustedes tienen que
pensar si realmente estamos reclamándole
mucho más a la vida que lo que realmente
le estamos aportando reclamamos por todo
pues reclamamos porque la selección no
clasificó por el tráfico por el gobierno
por la empresa por el examen de química
reclamo
antes que pasemos reclama y reclama
reclama y no nos cuestionemos nunca si
realmente algo estamos aportando la vida
saben por qué porque la valentía tiene
una característica única si no la usan
se acaba hoy
ustedes son más cobardes o más valientes
que ayer dependiendo lo que hayan hecho
ayer hoy son más valientes y más
cobardes que hace un año dependiendo lo
que hicieron del año pasado pero si el
año pasado estuvieron perdiendo el
tiempo como un modelo de excusas
seguramente hoy son más cobardes que
hace un año y si no eres valiente de
escobar 10 y eres cobarde está muerto de
miedo y si tienes miedo no vas a dar el
paso por lo tanto no vas a hacer nunca
un reto saben por qué porque el modelo
de excusa es el modelo perfecto fíjense
no hago nada no fracaso porque nunca lo
intento y me creo una mamá extracción y
paso criticando todo crítico cómo
manejar las políticas públicas y les
what críticos como una empresa debería
hacer para ganar más mercado crítico
como el técnico tuvo que haber para la
selección criticó todo
y sabemos todo y viene un man y te
pregunta oye ve y ya que lo sabes
no es que esto esto esto pero si no
tuviera esto fijo que lo hago es un
modelo perfecto no haces nada no
fracasas y te crees la matanza
impresionante y luís nos estaba
enseñando en ese momento que cuidado
estamos reclamando lemas de la vida de
lo que realmente estamos aportando
y bueno último día ahí me ven sucio
completamente porque no me vaya en una
semana
voy a 6 kilos menos ojeras mal comido
mal de hidratada mal dormido pero ahí
estaba yo avanzando tranquilo porque esa
ese día había sido el peor día de mi
vida yo cometió un error brutal y el
desierto es implacable no te permite
errores yo me equivoqué y puse mi ración
de proteínas en el bolsillo de mi ración
de alcohol para calentar el agua
entonces qué pasó que es el coche mezcló
con la proteína me tomé un trago y me
supo a gasolina entonces dije tú está es
el sol insolación algún relajo por allí
y estuve penn dejando ahí cinco estrados
más hasta que dije no no aguantas un
ratito me doy cuenta del error y cuando
uno comete el error tiene que remediarlo
puede regresar a ver a cualquier lado
pero la mejor forma es remendar el error
y a mí me tocó agarrar el batido y
botarlo y bote un medio tarro de agua
que no tenía y la comida equivalente a
una hora y media entonces te quedas en
un ayer que haces avanza más rápido para
recuperarte adelante o avanzas más lento
para gastar menos energía yo resolví
avanzar más lento dos horas después
había una alemana ya unos 50 metros
adelante se desploma con los vasos rotos
sangrando el tipo estaba revolcándose
ahí arena sangre como fuego está el
hambre más o menos yo estaba ahí
inconsciente sin saber qué hacer
temblando una muriéndose ahí en la misma
semana dos veces imagínense entonces tú
y disfruta hasta que llega un alemán
agarra una bengala la dispara llegó un
helicóptero el que vieron por allí lo
agarran al man y se lo llevan yo nunca
más lo vi al alemán pero ese día ese
momento agarrar la mochila la bote nadie
ni me senté a llorar porque esto que
había sido una carrera de aventura se
había convertido en realidad en un juego
de supervivencia y saben qué pasó ahí
llegó una francesa me dio la mano
y me acompaña un kilómetro a caminar
hasta recuperar mensajes por más jodidos
que estemos en la vida siempre habrá una
mano que nos va a levantar y ojalá
ustedes tengan la oportunidad y yo de
más veces en la vida dar la mano que
recibir la mano para levantar y bueno
eso ocurrió miren estos 20 metros
finales
los más bacanes de mi vida y los más
eternos de mi vida
[Música]
hace un año gracias
hace unos años chicos esto habría sido
imposible todo el mundo me dijo que era
una locura pero con trabajo con esfuerzo
realmente enfocado las cosas
extraordinarias se pueden hacer y bueno
y te sientes ramos pues en ese momento y
dices bueno sí ya corrí en el lugar más
caliente de la tierra bueno intentémoslo
misma frío y me embarco en este relajo
intentar meterme en la antártida es como
saben y ya se dieron cuenta yo soy mono
y yo no había vivido un invierno de
verdad yo no había pasado o sea no había
pisado nieve no había pasado un invierno
de verdad y mi concepto de frío era el
aire acondicionado así como ese man
pretende meterse al sitio más frío de la
tierra
allí hay el 90% del hielo del mundo ahí
se ha registrado la temperatura más baja
de la historia de la humanidad
- 89 grados centígrados y yo quería
correr allí si el kilómetro sin parar
sin parar más o menos al menos 30 grados
una locura completa la pregunta
inmediata es cómo lo vamos a hacer si tú
no creemos en el frío vas a tener que
entender el frío y nos metimos a
intentar resolverlo y se nos ocurrió
meternos en una fábrica de hielo
y esa vaina
abrí a las 7 de la mañana ya las 5 de la
mañana estaba metido había cinco de la
mañana habíamos puesto una caminadora y
hay una metí a correr a acompañar al
agua que se haga hielo y ahí va
entendiendo el frío sufriendo pero
entendiendo entendiendo entendiendo yo
vivo el tanquito en el piso 11 saqué la
cama la sala abrir las ventanas y dormía
todos los meses sin medias sólo en
pantaloneta sin camiseta sobre el
edredón y ahí y me levantaba de
madrugada con frío pero ahí me las
aguantaba llovía en quito salí a correr
me daba gripe vitamina c te recuperas y
así pasaba durante meses dejé en el
mañana con agua caliente sólo con agua
fría porque tenía que entender el frío
yo no me estaba yendo to el campus o sea
me estaba yendo me estaba yendo a la
antártida ya me estaba yendo y saben qué
pasa chicos nosotros somos
definitivamente la principal fábrica de
sueños pero también somos la máquina más
destructora de sueños hoy les haya haber
pasado en la mañana están acostados
viendo al techo todavía y dices yo te
quiero
de tanto quiero hacer una maestría en
esta universidad quiero aprender que era
aplicada esta empresa quiere emprender
el propio negocio y siguiendo acostado
viendo al techo empezamos no a pedazos
chiquitos no perdona un inglés no pero
soy chino no perdón dice que relajo y
así pasamos creando sueños matando
sueños creando sueños matando sueños eso
nos puede agarrar la vida entera insisto
como no sabemos cuándo nos vamos a morir
cuidado nos morimos sin hacer nada
porque el problema no es morirse el
problema es que la muerte nos llegue sin
haber hecho nada en realidad agarren ese
proyecto que tienen en mente y están
haciendo malabares y medios para
desbaratar los agarran lo intenten lo
hacer yo estaba ahí mira en el club
ahí estaba en la antártida menos ocho
grados ya concentrado final porque
apenas iba a abrir esa puerta me tocaba
correr 100 kilómetros seguidos porque
porque no había forma de parar se me
indicaron 2
no había forma de parar porque ahí me
tocaba co
a mí me tocó correr dos veces y parar
dos veces una del zapato otra por el
talón y ya pero seguía corriendo 16
obras me demoré este es un lugar mágico
imagínense en hay seis meses días seis
meses noche impresionante el cuerpo ya
yo me quedé ahí cuatro días en el tercer
día empiezas al hogar te comes seis mil
calorías por día seis mil que los días
por día para no bajar de peso
la locura eso en fichajes como 15
tratadas imagines ya por por día por día
por día para no perder peso se imágenes
la cantidad de frío que hay ahí ya hay
como se dan cuenta no hay ahora pues no
pues para que tú ver todos los gustos el
adiós llegan en ese punto entonces aquí
la verdad el sydney la de colombia la de
argentina de los que sean la importa
porque no pasa el tiempo es
impresionante nosotros como ecuatorianos
entendemos que el sol sale por el este y
termina acá acá aparecía allí miren esas
fotos a la una y media de la mañana
lo quisimos así cuatro días corriendo
como loco 16 horas me demoré bajé 6
kilos de peso para las mujeres ojo esto
es una dieta maravillosa yo en 16 horas
perdices kilos usted se puede tomar no
self en la mañana corren un cdp en la
tarde resultados inmediatos ya aquí en
el pueblo más discriminados en realidad
son 16 horas corriendo menos 30 grados y
bueno acabo esta carrera y
afortunadamente logró meterme o la
convertirme en el primer ecuatoriano en
acaba de esto y 2 y meterme en un grupo
de 14 personas en el mundo que hemos
sido capaces de correr más de 100
kilómetros en el lugar más caliente y
más frío de la tierra cómo se puede
hacer esto con planificación una vez que
tienen el reto se sientan a planificar
tengo que hacer esto esto esto esto y
esto
chévere que tengan un reto grande pero
si no mueven un dedo no va a pasar nada
enfoque y luego planifican y bueno claro
como ya la cabeza empieza a moverse si
ya corre este en el huevo más caliente
en el más frío qué te parece hacer esto
se le puede poner play a esto
es difícil que las personas entiendan
que me motiva
quien se atrevería a correr 240 km
durante una semana a 50 grados en el
lugar más caliente del planeta
el desierto del sahara
o correr 100 km en el más frío con
temperaturas que llegan hasta menos 30
grados en la antarte
como seres humanos buscamos descubrir
qué es lo que nos detiene en la vida
y mi motivación viene de entender cuáles
son mis límites y decidir qué hacer con
ellos para alcanzar nuevas metas y
evolucionar como persona
con disciplina perseverancia y
determinación es resuelto embarcando en
el desafío de conectar los puntos más
extremos en el planeta
y para esto descender es cerca de 4000
metros en el lugar más profundo de la
tierra
en sudáfrica
y desde allí correré hacia la superficie
o la de 22 horas hacia mi tierra 4
para enfrentar al ascenso del volcán
chimborazo y sus seis mil 268 metros
y punto de la tierra más cercano al sol
y todo esto con la esperanza de
convertir en el primer atleta
ecuatoriano que realice un nuevo récord
guinness
y mi equipo técnico me acompañará
durante todo el camino para asegurarse
de que mi cuerpo esté en la capacidad de
resistir los cambios extremos de
temperatura y demandas físicas en cada
lugar
muchas cosas pueden salir mal
me deshidratar en la mina
cómo reaccionaba mi cuerpo y mente ante
las extremas experiencia asignaturas
lo podría hacer
y que creen y bueno se me acabó el
tiempo y la verdad que no puedo
contarles qué pasó
no en serio entonces en realidad quería
agradecerles porque la verdad que se me
acabó el tiempo pero rápidamente
resumiendo les y nos metimos en un mayor
tocó entrenar
estuvimos sufriendo ahí y me desmayé 15
minutos la primera vez porque imagínate
40 gr de temperatura a 80 por ciento de
humedad relativa
esta es la mina dos horas y media
corriendo a 4.000 metros que les
recuerdan que los chilenos que quedaron
atrapados y el 2010 todos y ellos
quedaron a 700 metros nosotros tuvimos
que bajar casi seis veces más 4.200
cuatro mil y pico de metros una locura
eterna calor no hay circulación de aire
hay ratas abajo súper complicado pero lo
conseguimos
conseguimos el récord guinness al medio
maratón más rápido en el sitio más
profundo del planeta eso nos llevó
inmediatamente al chimborazo estuvimos
en el tipo de caso para intentar hacer
el nuevo enfoque que estaba muerto así
que toda mi confianza completamente en
mi equipo en mi equipo de trabajo tuve
bronquitis se me complicó el tema
respiratorio no podía respirar se me
habían tapado los los bronquios eran más
complicados imagínense en subir
puede respirar
cuando llegamos al campamento la cruz
roja dijo deben suspender esto o sea no
hay otra forma ya lo evaluamos con
nuestro equipo y revisamos cuáles son
las posibilidades cuáles no hicimos una
oración a dios hicimos una oración en la
montaña y subimos esto a los 6 mil 50
metros resolví no continuar porque ya
estaba roto ya había perdido gran parte
del peso en la memoria y todo estaba muy
muy agotado el es esteban mena
orgullosamente ecuatoriano y es la
persona más joven en la tierra que ha
coronado el everest sin oxígeno él lo
hizo cuando tenía 19 años hoy tiene 27 y
esteban me dijo mira me queda claro que
físicamente estás en la pero
quiero ver quiero ver si
psicológicamente
estás consciente que en 40 minutos más
estaremos en la cima y cuando me dijo 40
minutos se me pasó todo el esfuerzo que
habíamos hecho todo ese año y sabes que
lo único que alcancé a contestarle es si
faltan 40 minutos pues vamos y
efectivamente llegamos a la cumbre de 50
6 mil 280 metros y 71 horas atrás
habíamos estado en el sitio más profundo
de la tierra
muchísimas gracias chicos yo solamente
quiero demostrarles que las cosas
extraordinarias si se pueden hacer y
ustedes están en una edad maravillosa
para plantearse comer el mundo pero van
a tener que trabajar y trabajar bastante
porque estas cosas no son gratis solo
les quiero dejar una pregunta final nada
más todos aquí tenemos límites y ante
esos límites hay dos opciones la primera
acostumbramos nuestra vida a esos
límites y no va a pasar mayor cosa vamos
a tener una vida de actividades y no de
retos y la segunda entendemos que
nuestra vida es efímera que no sabemos
cuándo se nos va a acabar y más nos vale
que empecemos a vivirla y vivirla
significa que tomemos retos eso es que
exactamente están en su cabeza ahora
mismo y que al final del día cada uno
decide qué hacer con sus límites
muchísimas gracias por haberme escuchado
[Aplausos]